hello everyone welcome to the annual
holiday message from the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
those of you who've been listening for a
while know that we have a pattern near
the end of the year i roughly speaking
take
two weeks off around christmas and new
year's where i don't do
either a regular podcast or an ask me
anything episode for those who support
on patreon and the last podcast of the
year rather than me
interviewing someone or doing some kind
of formal
careful solo episode i just do a holiday
message and you know the holiday message
i think my original idea was it would be
10 minutes long
and i would say some of the highlights
of what had happened during the year and
so forth
but as happens when i do things it sort
of expanded
and now sort of i pick a topic that is
much more casual and maybe more personal
than a little bit less intellectual
perhaps than some of the things i would
normally do on the podcast i just chat
about it
okay so i'm not going to get much of an
overview of the year here
it's been quite a year 2020 in various
ways
i'm not going to go into that you've
probably had various ways in which it's
been
quite a year for you too so you can
imagine just uh
running through the highlights yourself
instead i thought i would take this
opportunity to talk
about part of the practice of doing
science
uh in particular i'm going to talk about
the phenomenon known as the screwy
universe
this is the idea that photons emitted
from
distant galaxies or the cosmic microwave
background very very far away
can actually be rotated as they travel
through empty space
let me be clear sorry that maybe let me
be correct first
the polarization of these photons can be
rotated as they travel through empty
space so a photon you know
can be thought of as an electromagnetic
wave right an electromagnetic wave is
literally
an electric field oscillating up and
down and a magnetic field
oscillating backward and forward
perpendicular to the
electric field and both of those two
things are perpendicular to the momentum
of the electromagnetic wave traveling in
some direction
so if you just ignore the magnetic field
and you look along the line of the
direction which the photon is coming
from the electric field is oscillating
up and down
in some direction okay that's the
polarization
every photon that you get or even any
classical electromagnetic wave
has an orientation when you look at it
in the sky its polarization is pointed
in some direction okay if you have lots
of light from an incoherent source
it can all sort of cancel out and you
can have essentially zero polarization
but an individual photon is polarized in
some direction
and some particular astrophysical
sources have a non-zero overall
polarization now if the laws of physics
were governed by
ordinary 19th century maxwell's
equations
then the polarization just stays
constant as the photon
travels to you okay but there are some
slightly different slightly uh more
avant-garde versions of physics where
you add some new fields in there or you
mess with it a little bit
in which these polarizations can rotate
and
there's two reasons why this is an
interesting thing to talk about right
now
number one it has personal resonance for
me
because this phenomenon in the
cosmological context
was i think first mentioned in my first
ever
published paper so i've been thinking
about this for a long time for
a sad number of decades now in fact and
so i thought i could
share with you some of why we were even
thinking about that back in my early
graduate student days
and secondly because there is now a
claim on the market i think the first
credible claim i've ever heard
that this might be true in other words
that this might actually have been
detected in particular in observations
of the cosmic microwave background
there's been a recent paper
by yuto minami and ichiro kamatsu which
says that they've looked very carefully
at the planck
telescope data of the cosmic microwave
background and they found some evidence
it's tentative evidence i mean maybe
people on twitter are arguing should you
even call it have evidence
it's a hint it's a little tiny
suggestion of an indication
that maybe there's a bit of rotation uh
the the technical term here is
is birefringence or cosmic birefringence
this rotation
of photons as they get to us and so
is that true what would it mean if it
were true should we trust it what should
our priors be
as good bayesians and things like that
there's been some discussion of this on
twitter and elsewhere
uh brian keating who's a cosmologist at
uc san diego he has a podcast and he
invited me on and we discussed that so
i'll link to that
in the show notes and i'll also link to
the actual paper which is appeared in
physical review letters from minami and
komatsu so you can read it and judge for
yourself
and uh ichiro also gave a talk on it so
i will uh link to that as well
the whole story dude now extends over 30
years
um is a very interesting story of how we
make progress in science you know a
relatively
low key story it's not you know big
nobel prize-winning news or anything
like that
but i've been there in the ground floor
for this particular story
and uh if it's true if it actually turns
out to be true
then it would be huge news there would
be nobel prizes handed out probably not
to me but you know you never know
and uh whether or not there's prizes
handed out it would be
absolutely an indication of physics
beyond the standard model of particle
physics
which is something we're all trying to
find uh in in any way
we can so again i wouldn't get too
excited about it i would not in the
sense that it's not exciting but the
sense that you should wait
to see what happens but this uh little
end of the year holiday message podcast
will bring you up to speed
both sort of uh why you should care
about this uh why it's interesting what
kind of attitude you should have toward
it
at the same time give me an excuse to be
a little self-indulgent and tell you
some interesting
episodes in my scientific biography uh
so with that let's go
imagine if you will your humble
correspondent arriving
into graduate school at harvard
university in september of
1988. so my own personal
trajectory to become a scientist and so
forth has been
rather unusual you know not the
straight-line path let's just put it
that way
and uh it's always been like that you
know it's never been
uh the royal road in any sense so it was
already weird
um for a couple of reasons and since i
already told you i'm going to be
self-indulgent i will let you know what
these reasons are
you know i went as an undergraduate to
villanova university a catholic school
on the main line outside
philadelphia and in many ways villanova
was a wonderful
place but you know really to be
perfectly honest
uh the reason why i went there in
addition to the fact that it had a
pretty good astronomy department
was that it was free they offered me a
full academic scholarship which
most places just don't do giving out
full academic scholarships and even back
then
college was expensive and you know we
were in that
that that difficult zone where you
didn't make enough money to get
financial aid
but uh you also didn't make enough money
to afford paying
for college so uh this was a good way to
go to college get an education on the
cheap
um and it was fun i did a lot of fun
things at villanova i
found philosophy for one thing i became
a philosophy minor i discovered my
interest in that because uh there were
required courses in philosophy
but also um i did a little bit of
research
uh i did research with ed guynan and
other people
who was my professor my advisor but it
was research on you know variable stars
right we would take data
on the light curves the variable stars
and we would look to try to analyze what
was going on in the stars
even back then i knew that that wasn't
what i wanted to do for a living i
wanted to do theoretical physics i'd
known that since i was 10 years old
it's just that at villanova at the time
the astronomy department was just
better in various ways than the physics
department one of which was you just got
to do research right away so that's what
i did
and i figured it's not that big a deal
right i mean you take the same physics
courses whether you're an astronomy
major or a physics major
so once i went to graduate school i
figured
i would just go into a physics
department and but
there was unbeknownst to me there were
some unfortunate sides of that or there
are some disadvantages of being there
for one thing there were no graduate
students at villanova right there was no
graduate program in physics or astronomy
so on the one hand you get extra
attention from the faculty
but on the other hand you don't get any
wisdom from
if you're an undergraduate you don't get
to talk to grad students or post-docs or
even faculty who are active in getting
students into graduate school so there
was so much i didn't know
about anything you know the importance
of taking the gres
i didn't even know that you got a
stipend for going to graduate school so
as soon as i looked at the tuition costs
at the various places i wanted to go
i thought instantly oh no i'm not going
to be able to do this this is a this is
a big problem what am i going to do
for those of you out there if you're if
you want to be a graduate
student in physics or astronomy or any
of the hard sciences
there's enough grant money floating
around that essentially no graduate
student
actually pays for tuition you either
get a some sort of fellowship that pays
your way if you're lucky
if you're not lucky you're a teaching
assistant and you earn your way but one
way or the other you actually make money
it's a tiny amount of money but you make
a little money going to graduate school
and
as a graduate student in a phd program
in science you do not come out with
student debt i had my undergraduate
student debt for quite a few years
because even though tuition was free the
rest of the package was not so
that's another podcast for another time
anyway eventually i did
get to the point where i was a senior
and i applied for graduate schools and i
only applied for physics departments i
knew i wanted to be a theoretical
physicist
i was ready to make that switch and i
applied to a bunch of places and i did
sort of okay
i got into some i didn't get into others
and perhaps unsurprisingly
the ones that didn't accept me were the
ones i really wanted to go to and i
think that i really wanted to go to them
even before they didn't accept me i
don't think it was just that they
became more attractive but in particular
harvard and princeton were my top two
choices
probably not in that order like i had
some vague feeling i wanted to go to
princeton and do string theory at the
time
um but whereas harvard didn't have many
string theorists at the time they had
one young person kumron fafa who's now
become
world famous but i didn't know any of
those details so
harvard put me on the waiting list and i
didn't really know what that meant
and in fact i actually took a train up
there my own dime to talk to people and
i was it was explained to me
um what being on the waiting list means
is that we think you're good enough
to be here but we don't have room for
you okay we can't afford you because
like i said
there's all this money that goes into
paying graduate students and so there is
a budget they let too many people in
they just won't be able to pay them that
which makes
sense so they did you know sort of hint
if i got up my own kind of fellowship
so i was free then they would let me in
that means more than hint they actually
said that out loud and
actually by the time i got home on the
train
i got a letter from the national science
foundation saying that i had a
fellowship that the nsf was giving me a
graduate fellowship and they would pay
for me to go to graduate school
so i waited a couple days eagerly
anticipating a notice from harvard and
didn't get that and eventually
i sort of contacted them again and they
said yeah we're still thinking about it
we've never accepted anyone here
from villanova before so we're not quite
sure what to do
so that was a bit of a blow i wasn't
quite sure what to do about that i had
very other good
options to go to but still you know part
of me wanted to go to harvard and
there's some romance to going to harvard
which
i i have to say once i went there it's
real i really you know
had a very special experience when i
eventually went to harvard
so you might want to know how did i get
in if they didn't want to let me in
well the answer is between my junior and
senior year at villanova
as an undergraduate i spent a summer at
the harvard smithsonian center for
astrophysics
so you have to know that the astronomy
department at harvard
is associated with something called the
harvard college observatory
which probably literally in the 1800s
was you know meant the telescope right
there were people who were hired to do
astronomy
separate from the astronomy department
although they were related to each other
but it's sometime i guess in the early
1970s
the harvard college observatory joined
forces it merged with the smithsonian
astrophysical observatory
to found this gigantic collection
of people doing research in astronomy i
think the biggest collection certainly
in the united states
is at the harvard smithsonian center for
astrophysics so
i had done research there with sally
balloonis who was
a former villanova undergraduate you
know 20 years prior so
she had been a villanova undergraduate
had kept in touch with ed geinden my
advisor at villanova and so forth
and so over the summer i got to travel
to cambridge and
did research with her again on variable
stars that's what they did
uh got to know that's part of why i
really wanted to go to harvard as a
graduate student i just fell in love
with the place while i was there
so i called up sally and i said you know
the physics department seems to be
giving me the runaround here
is there any chance that the astronomy
department at harvard would let me in
even though i didn't apply and she said
well i don't know i'm not even in the
astronomy apartment she was one of the
smithsonian
people but she walked over to the office
of josh grindley who was a harvard
professor and chair of the astronomy
department explained to him
uh my that i had uh my funding all by
myself and i wanted the astronomy uh to
be the graduate student astronomy
department
and shaw said well why doesn't the
physics department let them in is there
something wrong with him
and she said no there's something wrong
with them so josh to his enormous credit
you know he never heard of me before
uh it was literally two days before the
deadline
for the last you know people to accept
their graduate school
offers and he went uh to the physics
department which is a schlep
because it was a 15 minute walk away the
astronomy department is separate from
everything else at harvard
uh got my file brought it around to all
of the members of the graduate
admissions committee in the astronomy
department got them to sign off and
accepted me and he said he would do this
on one condition he called me up and he
said
look i'm only going to do this if you
say if we let you in you will come
and so i said sure i want to come and
that's what i did
so that's why in september of 1988 i
ended up in the astronomy department as
a new graduate student at harvard
and again you know much like an
undergraduate i could still take all the
physics course i wanted
to take so and i ended up over the
course of my five years at harvard
taking lots of physics courses
i even taught a general relativity
course together with my friend ted pine
to the other grad students
at uh the astronomy department at
harvard and the notes for those
that lectures that we gave as as
graduate students
eventually evolved into the textbook
that i wrote space-time and geometry
and so i also took courses over at mit
and ended up working with people at mit
like eddie fari and alan guth and so
forth and so it was a wonderful
experience overall
but at the time right when i'm brand new
i didn't know anything
and it was all very scary it was all
very intimidating
and one thing that happens is one of the
nice things about the astronomy
department at harvard for
incoming grad students is exactly
because of this
harvard smithsonian center for
astrophysics there's a huge
number of people there a huge number of
phd astronomers doing research okay so
just
huge amounts of resources for people who
want to be astronomers and
learn it and be graduate students and
get a good education so
at many places i won't name names but at
many places you know you can be a grad
student and you can kind of coast
through uh depending on how you interact
with your
advisor who's the one person who really
matters they can either you know
drive you crazy demanding work or they
can kind of ignore you and you know you
can sort of drift a little bit
but at the harvard astronomy department
because there were so many
people there who are phds they actually
had what is called a phd thesis
committee that would meet every six
months to check up on your progress like
no place i've ever been has ever done
anything like this
uh before but that was far off at the
time at the time i was just assigned
kind of randomly
an advisor right because they as soon as
you arrive
they assign you an advisor and then you
may or may not
stay with that advisor to do your phd
but they want someone there who is a
faculty member
to sort of keep you in line answer
questions for you check
up on how you're doing stuff like that
so i was assigned
george field who i had never heard of
before
uh he's he was an older guy he still is
he's still around he's
still one of uh my favorite people in
the world we still talk all the time and
i'll even tell you a little bit about
the research we're still doing
uh in a minute but george i later
realized was an extremely
distinguished theoretical astrophysicist
but in
rege in in sort of a specialty that i
knew very little about i mean he had
worked on the interstellar medium
the intergalactic medium magnetic fields
galaxy formation things like that my
interests were in sort of particle
physics
general relativity and how they apply to
cosmology
but purely by accident george
had become interested in those things so
george was actually
um stolen away from berkeley by harvard
because when they formed the center for
astrophysics right
in the 70s when they joined the harvard
college observatory with the smithsonian
astrophysical
observatory they wanted to hire a big
name to be the first director
you know to get the place off the ground
and so forth and they hired george
george
was the first the founding director of
the harvard smithsonian center for
astrophysics
but he had retired from that job a few
years ago
and you know he didn't he wasn't that
active doing research while he was a
director he had thrown himself into
being the director you know
bringing up this new place and so he
kind of had a little bit of a luxury
when he stopped being director
to pick and choose what kind of research
he wanted to do and being the kind of
person he is
he didn't want to just do the same thing
he had done before
he wanted to do something new so again
being the person he is and
you know a big influence on me and my
attitude toward
uh trying different things and lifelong
learning and things like that
george said well what what would i do if
i were a student
right and he knew about you know this is
the late 80s he knew that there was a
burgeoning interest
in particle physics and cosmology and
their intersection and so forth using
the early universe as a particle
accelerator
and so he said well if i were a graduate
student in theoretical physics i would
go to a summer school
that's this thing where you sort of go
to some exotic location as a student and
you hear lectures from the great people
so he did that he went to a summer
school you know over the course of his
career he'd given
lectures at summer schools all the time
but here he went as a student
uh in as a summer school for quantum
field theory
and particle physics and theoretical
physics okay and
uh had a great time the summer school
was at les zeus i later went to a lash
summer school myself it's a wonderful
institution
and interestingly you know it was all
these lectures
from particle physics physicists field
theorists
and you know the late 80s it's hard to
exactly characterize
what was going on but it was a little
bit of a slow point
in theoretical particle physics okay um
we had discovered all the stuff in the
standard model except for you know the
top quark and the higgs boson but
everyone thought we would
discover those at some point we
certainly discovered the w
and the z um and you know cosmology was
a little bit stuck we had not yet found
the cosmic microwave background
anisotropies we were trying to measure
the hubble constant and so forth so you
know it was overall a slow point
and when that happens people's minds
sort of wander a little bit and they
they look for interesting new problems
so one of the sets of lectures that
george sat in on at his leisure
summer school was by roman jakief who is
a professor at mit
just down the road from harvard a very
accomplished
senior mathematical theoretical
physicist
roman is probably best known for being
the co-discoverer of
anomalies anomalies in quantum mechanics
are
when you have a classical theory that
has some symmetries
but then you quantize those symmetries
the symmetries can be when you quantize
those theories
the symmetries can be broken by the
process of quantization
and this actually has empirical effects
and it's been observed and you know so
the
adler bell jakiev anomaly is a big deal
in particle physics and quantum field
theory and for years
uh roman's intellectual interest had
driven him to think about
physics in two dimensions that is to say
two dimensions of space
one dimension of time so what we often
call two plus one dimensions okay
we all know that two plus one equals
three but two plus one dimensions means
two plus two dimensions of space
one dimension of time and this is
physically very interesting because you
can make materials
right like graphene or whatever they
didn't know about graphene at the time
but they knew you could make materials
where all the interesting physics was
confined to a two-dimensional plane
but it's also for someone like roman who
is extremely mathematical
it's mathematically fascinating because
the geometry and topology and all these
different things that go on
in three dimensions are just different
than in four dimensions so there's a
whole new mathematical playground and so
roman
gave lectures at leisure on his two plus
one dimensional physics playground
and in particular there was a particular
effect in
electromagnetism which is that in uh
three plus one dimensions in the
ordinary world there's only so much you
can do with the electromagnetic field
and basically maxwell had done it
back in the 19th century you can always
you know add new particles and forces
and whatever but
electromagnetism by itself was pretty
cut and dried okay
but it turns out that in two plus one
dimensional space time there is an
extra term that you can write down in
the equations of motion
for the electromagnetic field one that
just isn't allowed in three plus one
dimensions
and it's called the churn simon's term
and that's named after
ss churn and jim simons jim simons you
might know
because later he left mathematics and
founded renaissance technologies
uh and made a whole lot of money let's
put it that way the renaissance
technologies uh tracks
the prices of things in you know stocks
and
and various things i don't even know
what they what they track right
bonds i suppose um equities
and they sell them very very rapidly and
buy them on the advice of this big code
that they built and so he's made a lot
of money
doing that and that's why the simon's
foundation named after jim simons
is now such a good patron of
physics and science more broadly in
mathematics because
jim simons was a very accomplished
mathematician before he went off and
made a lot of money
so the churn simon's term is something
that you can that is unique to
three-dimensional
manifolds okay so two plus one counts in
this case
and what simons and chern had been
interested in was the topology
of these three-dimensional manifolds and
so there's a
specific kind of topological invariant
that
only works in three dimensions and it's
called the churn simon's term okay
and if you want more details on this i
advocate that you check out my biggest
ideas in the universe video on geometry
and topology where i talk a little bit
about it there just a very little bit
um but anyway so roman had taken this
topological mathematical structure
that churn and simons had invented and
realized it had to use in physics
it could you could put it into the
equations of motion for the
electromagnetic field and it would
change them a little bit
it was kind of like giving the photon a
mass
you all know or you should know or you
maybe you've heard or maybe i'm telling
you now for the first time
photons are massless okay in the real
world photons have zero mass
and this thing you could do with the
turn simon's term in three dimensions
was
like giving the photon a mass but not
really okay and i'm not going to go into
details about why
it wasn't really true but anyway it has
a lot of implications for a lot of
things still tren simon's theories are
incredibly interesting to mathematical
physicists even today
so george is sitting there listening to
roman talk about you know this term that
you write down in two plus one
dimensions
and in his innocent little astrophysical
way he said
but come on i mean if you want me to be
interested in this there has to be
some way that we can do this in three
plus one dimensions in the real world
you know this is the difference between
the radical astrophysicist and
mathematical physicists the
astrophysicist is always going to want
to bring it down to the real world okay
and the mathematical physicist is
perfectly fine
if the real world comes by to visit
sometimes but doesn't stay off and stay
overnight or anything like that
and romania he thought about and he said
look you can't
because if you tried to the only way to
do something like that would be to pick
out
a preferred direction of space time and
then think of the
two plus one dimensions as being
perpendicular to that preferred
direction of space time then you could
do it
but the problem with that is that it
violates lorenz invariants
lorenz and variance is a foundational
principle of modern physics it's what
einstein
uh used as the bedrock for the special
theory of relativity even though it goes
back earlier to lorentz and other people
right and it's the basic idea that you
can't tell how fast you're moving there
is no
preferred reference frame in space or in
space time with respect to which you can
measure your velocity
so if you measure the laws of physics in
one reference frame and then measure
them in some other reference frame
they will look the same to you okay so
row manchester's point to george was
if you did just force yourself to make
some kind of
version of a churn simon's term in
electromagnetism
but in the real world not in this fake
three-dimensional world you would have
to do it at the expense of violating the
rents invariants
and so george's answer to that was okay
let's do that and again i think that he
was aided a little bit by sort of
not being a working particle physicist
or quantum field theorist like the kind
of thing that would just be anathema
to those people he said well yeah let's
try it let's see what happens okay
so he convinced roman that that would be
a good idea
and that's where i came in so that was
the summer right and before i came to
harvard i arrived at harvard
and the two of them had agreed to get
back together and talk about this and
they each brought
their graduate students roman's graduate
student eventually decoupled he went
somewhere else
but i you know hung along for this um
project
they wanted to work on and this is a
very typical way that as a new graduate
student you get involved in a project
either your advisor
or your advisor and their friends has
some idea they're just beginning to work
out
and they bring you along to sort of
catch up and help them along the way so
i'm being very very clear here like none
of the real intellectual heavy lifting
on this was originally mine
i did make contributions to the paper
but it wasn't my idea
the idea came even before i arrived in
in cambridge
so we sat down i remember very vividly
you know we were in george's office
roman came over and uh it was all very
intimidating there were so many books
uh with all these titles about that sort
of hinted at
treasures that i did not have access to
because i just begun my theoretical
physics education
you know one of the side uh
disadvantages of being at an
undergraduate institution was not just
you didn't talk to graduate students
but you didn't get to take any graduate
classes right you know most
undergraduates who want to grow up to be
theoretical physicists and who go to
places like caltech or berkeley or
whatever
will sit in on or take graduate classes
so that when they actually arrive in
graduate school they have a
a leg up a little bit of an advantage i
had none of those advantages so i didn't
even take quantum field theory my first
year
in grad school whereas many people take
one and field theory as juniors or
seniors in undergraduate school so
catching up has been the story of my
life ever since then
and it was definitely the case here
because here's you know roman and george
who know
you know even though uh george is not a
work was not a working
quantum field theorist he knew special
relativity he knew classical field
theory inside out
uh he knew the lingo the jargon the
notation the mathematical way of writing
things and he had already come up with a
way that he was proposing that we could
actually
experimentally test this idea
so i was completely lost i had no idea
what they were talking about they were
writing equations on the blackboard
you know i promised myself i would go
home and try to catch up and you know
look at some books on field theory
which i ultimately did um but basically
here was the idea what george noticed
was you can hear um
caliban in the background i think he's
meowing because it's almost dinner time
anyway um he said look okay so you have
what you what the point of this idea was
when when roman said
this theory would violate lorenzen
variance one way of thinking about it is
if you
had been just in two plus one dimensions
just in a three-dimensional universe
then there's a parameter there's a
number that goes into the turn simon's
theory which basically says how
important how big is this effect that
you're adding to conventional
electromagnetism
and it's just a number right and it's
the turn simon's parameter
but in the real world in four plus in
three plus one dimensions in
four-dimensional space-time
that parameter gets promoted to a vector
it points in some direction in
space-time okay
and that's why it violates the rents
invariance it's kind of like the ether
right it's it's a universal vector field
that fills all of space-time or it would
be if it existed
and it is something with respect to
which you can measure are you in the
rest frame of this vector field it says
it's a space-time
vector field not just a spatial vector
field so it doesn't necessarily point
north south east west it can point in
the time-like direction
for example and in fact without knowing
any
other specific reason why this vector
field should exist at all
it would be very natural if this vector
just pointed in the time-like direction
with respect to the cosmological rest
frame right
we know that in special relativity there
is no preferred rest frame
as far as the laws of physics are
concerned but in our real world universe
the stuff in space-time defines a rest
frame right
we talk about we're being at rest with
respect to the cosmic microwave
background or the rest frame of the
galaxies that we live in
okay so there is a natural cosmological
rest frame
and if you had to pick if you had to
choose where this
vector would be pointing it would be
perpendicular
to surfaces of constant time
in that reference frame okay so you
would think that roughly speaking your
guess
would be that this vector field would be
completely time like
okay it would not in other words pick
out a preferred direction in space
it would only pick out a preferred
direction in space time
that was a natural guess okay and so
what george had figured out he'd
written down all the equations and he'd
gone through and he'd solved them and he
basically
done undergraduate electromagnetism but
he
you know what you would derive the
propagation of electromagnetic waves
right that's an elementary exercise you
do
in electromagnetism but he did it in the
in the presence of this new
modification this new turn simon's term
and he found this effect he found that
it would change the polarization state
of a photon or of an electromagnetic
wave if an electromagnetic wave
traveled through space in the presence
of this new turn simon's effect its
polarization would rotate
okay so that's the kind of thing you
know like i said any undergraduate could
have done it
if they've been told to do exactly that
you know part of being a good scientist
is deciding
what to do what questions are interested
in uh are interesting enough to work on
you know what what equations you should
write down and solve
so that part is hard but you know once
you had them there
anyone could have solved these equations
that was not really the hard part
the reason why it was very useful that
we had george on this project not only
that he you know pushed it forward and
came up with the idea
uh but he said and you know what we can
actually
test this being a real theoretical
astrophysicist he knew about real
phenomena in the universe like galaxies
and stuff like that
and here's the problem with testing this
idea you say
there's some source out there in the
universe it emits a polarized beam of
light
traveling toward you and it gets rotated
by this effect
this effect that is these days called
cosmic birefringence back then we didn't
know about that it's a word borrowed
from the condensed matter
literature um so sure
you can rotate a polarization of a
photon via cosmological birefringence
but all that says is that the
polarization is different when it
arrives at you than it was when it left
how do you know what it was when it left
right like
that's the hard part this is often the
case in astronomy how do you know where
it started this is the classic problem
of
distances in astronomy you know how
bright things look but how bright were
they
at their source that would tell you if
only you knew that's the tricky part
so likewise for the polarization but
george knew that there were these things
called
radio galaxies and radio galaxies are
just galaxies that emit
radio waves but very very typically
there's a reason why
these galaxies are emitting radio waves
you probably
have seen these pictures of black holes
with
jets coming out of them right if you
have a black hole with an accretion disk
around it
there's a jet of material that is
ejected along the north axis and the
southern axis of the black hole
and this can happen on galaxy sized
scales right and if you
are lucky enough to be looking at the
jet you would see this is a very bright
quasar
but if you're looking perpendicular to
the jet you can actually see the jet
so you can actually take a picture in a
radio telescope of
this galaxy on the sky and it's not just
a diffuse
blob it has a direction there's a
direction in which this
jet is pushing matter away from the
black hole
at the center okay and what happens is
there are magnetic fields
in this jet and they are stretched along
the direction in which they're being
pushed right
so not only do you see this jet
on the sky in the picture you've taken
in your telescope but you can also
predict ahead of time there will be a
magnetic field stretched in the same
direction
okay now i'm doing going through this
carefully because it matters that you
know the direction of everything
at the source even though you can't go
there and measure it you need some
physical intuition
okay and the physics tells you the
magnetic field should be
along the same direction pointing in the
same direction as the jet
and what happens is in that jet there
are all these electrons and there are
other charged particles but electrons do
almost all the work
and when you put an electron in a
magnetic field it sort of goes around in
circles
perpendicular to the magnetic field okay
and an electron
going around in circles will emit
electromagnetic waves
all the light around you as any of you
know if you heard my quantum mechanics
talks
comes from electrons in motion emitting
electromagnetic waves
so so visualize this if you want to
um on the sky you see a jet it's it's
oriented in some direction you know the
magnetic field is pointing in that
direction
so you know the electrons are rotating
perpendicular to that directions they're
going up and down if the jet is oriented
left and right
the electrons are circling in a way that
tu looks like up and down
and when they emit an electric field it
is therefore
polarized vertically up and down the
polarization of the photons or the
electromagnetic waves coming from those
electrons
is in the same direction of their motion
therefore there's a very strong
prediction there is a
and this so we haven't gone to crazy
physics yet this is ordinary
astrophysics
um there's a very strong uh intuition
expectation prediction
that the polarization of these radio
jets
will be perpendicular to the direction
in which they're stretched along the sky
okay so this gives you not a standard
candle but a standard polarization
this gives you something in the sky
where you can look for radiation that is
polarized in radio telescopes
and you know what the polarization was
when it left
the galaxy so you can compare to what it
is when you look for it when you observe
it here
and you can see whether or not it's been
rotated okay
so just to summarize in case you you
know you haven't
this is there's a lot of material i know
i know it very well i was very excited
this is this is the beginning of my life
as a working research scientist
um we had this crazy theory churn
simon's theory that violates
lorenzen variants and its uh
experimentally
testable prediction is that it causes
birefringence it rotates
the polarization from photons traveling
through empty space
and in these radio galaxies you have a
source where you know what the
polarization was
so you can test it and furthermore
the more the photon travels through
empty space the more
rotation you predict right so not only
can you just look at a bunch of radio
galaxies
but you can look at radio galaxies as a
function of distance
and if this effect were real you would
think that radio galaxies
nearby should have almost no rotation
whereas radio galaxies far away should
have a lot of rotation a lot of
birefringence
that's where the graduate student comes
in that's this was my job my job was to
go through the literature
and you know back then we didn't even
have computers on our desks you had to
actually go through the
journal printed on pieces of paper and
xerox them and you know type them into a
terminal somewhere and so i defined a
bunch of
data not only for the polarization of
radio galaxies but also for their
distances
and this was very exciting to me and i
did it while you know at night trying to
learn enough about
field theory to understand what in the
world we were doing
and uh i did it i found 160 galaxies
where i could get both the polarization
data
and the distance data and i plotted them
and i learned how to make plots and you
know the
the software that we had available to us
at cfa
um and lo and behold there was no effect
okay don't get your hopes up here
we put a limit on it right that's what
you can do that's what we expected to do
there was
zero i none of us ever thought there was
zero expectation
that we would find a non-zero rotation
okay we're trying to put a limit on it
so
here's where i can step back and say why
would you do that like why
would you work so hard not that hard
would you work a little bit hard
on um showing that something you expect
to be zero is zero
well you know it's a high risk high
reward kind of thing right on the one
hand we didn't expect it
to be a non-zero effect in the data but
on the other hand
if it had been uh it would have been
huge right violating lorenz invariants
oh my goodness
and in fact at that time 1988
there weren't a lot of experimental
tests of lorenzen variants okay i mean
there were some
sort of model independent tests of
lorenzen variants in other words you
just
come up with some experiment and then
you rotate it or you move it at some
speed and do it again
but there wasn't any systematic
investigation of ways the lorenzen
variants could reasonably be broken
so the really nice cool thing about this
turn simon's theory was
even though it broke lorenzen variants
it didn't break anything else
it didn't cause um it didn't break gauge
invariants or charge conservation or
anything like that for other reasons
otherwise it was a perfectly respectable
theory there were some worries about
i'll get to in a second there were some
worries about the fact that
you could maybe violate energy
conservation you could sort of
create energy from this rigid background
vector field but that's
that turns out to be a fixable problem
and interestingly you know like
i i was learning enough about what other
people kind of did in research-wise in
theoretical physics to know
that what we were doing was a little bit
disreputable
you know violating lorenz invariants no
one else did that
but uh to everyone's surprise uh
nowadays right you know um a certain
number of decades later that paper that
we ended up writing which ended up being
my first ever published paper
i had another paper that i did as an
undergraduate but we were so slow doing
that one that it didn't come out until
after
uh our turn simon's paper um it has like
well over a thousand citations it really
sort of
launched not just uh investigations in
the cosmological birefringence but
really the whole program of inventing
reasonable ways of violating the rents
and variants and
then testing them experimentally and
it's a good lesson because you know even
though the theories themselves were
certainly speculative
they were all very experimentally
testable in different ways some of them
with ground-based experiments some of
them with astrophysical experiments
and that's always something that
physicists are going to like
to do you know because if you even if
you think that it's unlikely you'll find
an effect
finding it is real really really
important and sometimes you just have to
like
go on a fishing expedition and see
what's out there okay
so there these days uh there's huge
numbers of
people and experimental teams trying to
test lorenzen variants in various ways
and i i think it's true that you know we
were the first paper that sort of
had a respectable um
field theory basis for how lorenzen
variants could be violated and then
tested okay so you know it was much more
respectable in retrospect than i thought
it was at the time
but anyway uh we you know i actually did
the the sort of
computing here right like i looked in
this i learned enough statistics
to learn how to test our hypothesis
showed that it was
not um uh there was no evidence that
there was any birefringence put limits
on it okay
there's a numerical limit we could put
on and numerically that limit works out
to be
roughly the size of the universe because
we were looking at
galaxies that were roughly the size of
the universe away
okay so we could have left it there and
roughly speaking we did leave there i
think roman left it there he
he moved on to other things but george
and i were always bugged by the fact
that
you know the the physical manifestation
that we were testing was kind of cool
right these photons moving around having
their polarizations rotated
but the theoretical justification for it
was entirely pulled out of a hat just
have a vector field out there in space
whatever um so we thought about what
that meant and where it could come from
and it turns out
there's sort of a more respectable
version of almost exactly the same
theory
and that is instead of having a vector
field have a scalar field
okay so the difference is that what a
scalar field means is that
at every point in space there's a value
to the field but for a vector field
there is a value and also a direction
right a vector just think of a little
arrow pointing in space time
it has a magnitude and also a direction
a scalar field
just has a magnitude it's just a number
at every point in space like the
temperature of the air in a room at
every point there's a temperature okay
that's a scalar field
but we're imagining a fundamental scalar
field right like imagine that there is
some new ingredient to nature
this scalar field and we're imagining
this scalar field
rolls down a hill this is something that
quantum field theorists and particle
physicists and cosmologists
do all the time the higgs boson relies
on this idea
you imagine there's a potential for your
scalar field
and the field wants to roll down to the
bottom of the potential
like a ball rolling to the bottom of a
hill okay
the difference is for something like the
higgs boson the higgs has a potential
and it rolls down to the bottom but it
rolls down very very quickly in some
tiny fraction of a second
we were imagining a hill that was very
very gentle
so our scalar field would roll down it
but it would take the lifetime of the
universe it would take
over 10 billion years to actually move
in any uh substantial way
okay what does this have to do with our
turn simon's theory
well uh you can take this vector field
changing with time and in principle it
could change with space
right and so by doing calculus to it you
could say well
what is the gradient of this scalar
field what is the
vector that defines the magnitude and
direction
in which it is changing so if the scalar
field is the same value everywhere in
space but is changing
in time it has a gradient that is purely
time-like
a vector that is pointing purely in the
time-like direction
whereas if the scalar field were not
changing in time at all
but we're changing in some direction in
space then its gradient would be purely
space-like and all the different
possible things in between
so it turns out that the idea of a
scalar field in fact technically
speaking it would be called a
pseudo-scalar field
because it's a parity it has negative
parity instead of positive parity
i'm not going to talk about what that
means in fact as i'm saying it i realize
if you're not a physicist you might
think i'm saying p-a-r-o-d-y parody
i'm actually saying p-a-r-i-t-y parody
the how things act when you show them in
a mirror or something like that okay so
if you looked at this scalar field in a
mirror it would go to minus its own
value that's what it means to be a
pseudoscaler field
so the reason why i'm saying this is
because there has been
way before we came along there were this
idea that there could be scalar fields
that coupled to electromagnetism
in exactly the same way as our vector
field did if you just
talked about the gradient instead of
talking about the field itself
so literally the pion if you think about
the pion particle as a scalar field
it couples to photons in exactly this
way
the axion which is a hypothetical
particle but axions also coupled to
electromagnetism in this way the only
difference the real difference what we
were caring about was again
this particular pseudoscaler field that
we were inventing
would evolve over cosmological time
scales okay it would not
rush to hit the bottom of its potential
and just sit there it would slowly
slowly
evolve over cosmic time and so we wrote
a paper about that
and then we wrote various other papers
just a couple other papers because you
realize that if you did have
in the early universe this kind of
pseudoscalar field
rapidly evolving it could dump its
energy
into the electromagnetic field and
therefore be a source of
of uh magnetogenesis it could create
magnetic fields in the early universe
and that's a good thing to do because
there are magnetic fields in the late
universe now
and we're not completely sure where they
came from so i told you i was going to
say what george and i were still
thinking about we are still thinking
about
specific models in which you can create
magnetic fields in the early universe
from some rolling pseudoscaler field in
exactly this way and he's
using exactly this coupling okay but
most of
the research that i did and george did
and roman did subsequent to then had
nothing to do with this particular
turn simon's theory or anything like
that you know we moved on to other
things and you know other people got
very excited about laurence and variance
but i
was not really paying that much
attention to it until so now move
forward
uh seven years okay so 1990 so i said in
1988 i arrived at harvard but our paper
you know takes time to write and it
takes a year to get through the
refereeing and so forth
it technically appeared in 1990 uh so
seven years after that in 1997
i was already on my second postdoc so i
had gotten my phd
i'd done a first postdoc at mit for
three years and i was on my second
postdoc
in santa barbara okay at the institute
for theoretical physics now the kavli
institute for theoretical physics the
kitp
and uh it was a wonderful time but i was
beginning to realize that i was in
trouble
okay because um like i said in 1988
or even you know four or five years
later there wasn't a lot exciting going
on
in theoretical particle physics and
cosmology and
so i did perfectly well just
uh doing things i thought were cool
right violating the rents and variants
i worked on time machines uh in general
relativity
i worked on textures and other
topological defects stuff like that
super gravity is the grab bag of
different things but by the time it was
1997
um things had happened that were really
exciting
in cosmology we had discovered in 1992
the kobe satellite had discovered the
anisotropies of the cosmic microwave
background
and people were very very excited in
cosmology about using the microwave
background the cmb
to test cosmological models to constrain
parameters of the universe
so there was a whole bandwagon of people
who had lept on that and i was not on
that bandwagon
meanwhile on the theoretical particle
physics side of things people had
discovered
dualities and so uh witten and cyborg
had discovered in super
sim symmetry and super gravity there
were these duality relationships
and then joe polczynski used that in
string theory to invent d
brains and string theory duality and
then juan muldacena found the adscft
duality and so forth and so
everyone on that side of the ledger was
working on dualities and the second
superstring revolution
and i was not working in any of these
exciting areas and uh
i know that there's a certain romantic
component to being a professional
academic that says well you should just
work on what interests you but as i tell
my students
you should really work on the
intersection of what interests you
and what interests the rest of the world
and that
the interest of the rest of the world
had shifted and i had not shifted along
with it so
when i applied for my first postdoc i
was a hot property on the postdoc market
but when i applied for my second i was
not
and here in 1997 i should be applying
for faculty jobs and i was not
a hot property on the job market uh
which is a polite way or a
sensationalized way of saying i was not
getting any jobs i was not even getting
on any short lists for any faculty jobs
so i realized that i needed to
[Music]
think of ways which i could write papers
that i cared about that i thought were
interesting
um but that the rest of the world also
thought were interesting and i wasn't
that excited about either the microwave
background or the second super string
revolution so i was a little bit stuck
so just by accident um
in 1997 i got an email from george field
and he said yeah you should read this
story on the front page of the new york
times about this finding in cosmology
and so i said okay sure you know i was
he was in cambridge massachusetts i was
in california
i said okay i'll read it at some point
and then the next day he emails me again
he says no you really got to read this
right now it's kind of important so i
said okay
okay i read it and then i read the story
the new york times the front page not
the front page of the science times
literally the front page of the new york
times
and it says you know i forget the title
of it it was something like
you know astronomers find evidence for
preferred direction in space or
something like that okay
and you know something like you know
when you read stories in the popular
press
it's perfectly okay that they get
excited about claims that would be
dramatic if they were true but you need
to be able to sort of normalize them and
say but they're probably not true
you have to be able to judge a little
bit what claims are worth taking
seriously and just the fact that
something
in the new york times is not enough to
make me take it seriously
but on george's recommendation i read it
and i instantly realized something
that this paper uh which talked with
this article in new york times which
talked about a new finding by two
scientists who i i didn't know
personally uh bourgeon
and uh joseph ralston had
looked at data of polarized radio
galaxies
and in fact when i looked closely it
said that they had 160 radio galaxies
and since it had been my first ever
published paper seven years before
i knew that number 160 that's the number
of radio galaxies who i had typed in
when i was a young graduate student when
we wrote our paper it seemed to me that
it was too much of a coincidence
uh if if they had the same number of
radio galaxies for doing something very
different so i
downloaded their actual paper by then
you know the internet was
all the rage and we had the archive you
can just find the paper okay
and here's what they had done linden
ralston they had
looked at exactly our data set right and
we didn't collect the data so it's not
our data set but the data that we looked
at
but what george and roman and i had done
was just
look you know for our simplicity and
peace of mind
we assumed that this vector field that
we were trying to constrain
was time-like right i talked about the
fact you have a vector field in
space-time
it could be space-like or time-like or
whatever just to make things simple we
imagine that it was purely
time-like and then we constrained that
so you we could easily
have looked for space-like effects and
that would be
so what we had predicted was that all
throughout the sky
if this effect were real there'd be a
rotation either clockwise
or counterclockwise but by some definite
amount
everywhere except that farther away
galaxies would have a bigger effect okay
so we would get either
every galaxy in the universe would be
rotated in its polarization
clockwise by a little bit or every
galaxy in the universe would have its
polarization of its photons rotated
counterclockwise by a little bit or
something like that
okay that's what you would expect for a
time-like vector field violating the
rensom variants
if you have a space-like vector field
that means you're literally
having a preferred axis in the universe
you can point in a certain direction of
the sky and go the vector field points
in that direction
in the opposite direction it points
anti-correlated
so in that case what you expect is that
in one hemisphere of the sky in one half
of the sky
the polarizations we rotated
counterclockwise a little bit
and in the other hemisphere they'd be
rotated clockwise a little bit okay
we didn't look for that effect so
nodding and ralston had claimed to look
for that effect
and find it without huge statistical
significance
okay so i didn't believe that george
didn't believe it like
even though we didn't look at it and you
know again if you have ever done a
scientific project like this
when you're doing it you play with the
data you plot it in different ways you
get to know it you get to know yeah that
point it always appears over there on
the plots and things like that
so it just didn't smell right and not
only you know like we said we didn't
expect
our original paper to find any effect
much less a space like effect that would
be very hard to explain
certainly it wouldn't it would be much
harder to explain with sort of a rolling
scalar field
because rather than rolling you would
have a situation where the scalar field
was
fixed frozen but its value would change
over
uh space which is just a little bit
weird i don't know it could have
happened i mean yet that's why you have
to do it that's why you have to
look at the data but i i was still
skeptical i thought that it was more
likely in my bayesian
assignment of priors that they had made
a boo-boo and in fact
they had and their basic booboo was the
following remember i went to great
length to tell you that your expectation
should be that the polarization of these
radio galaxies is perpendicular
to the direction in which the jet is
oriented okay 90 degrees away
now there is an ambiguity here okay you
can't tell
polarization is a direction but it's
just
a direction modulo 180 degrees
okay so in other words you know that
there is a line
along which the polarization happens but
there's no orientation to that line
forward or backward so if you rotate the
polarization by
180 degrees it's exactly the same
polarization you had before
okay so when i say it's perpendicular at
90 degrees
90 or 270 or some multiple thereof
so what donald and ralston did for some
reason which i don't know uh
they assumed that the natural intrinsic
polarization of these radio galaxies was
parallel to the radio jet not
perpendicular to it
and so they had a puzzle because you
know
most of them are actually at 90 degrees
and so they thought
that there that the fact that most of
the polarizations are at 90 degrees
to the jet indicated that it had been
rotated
by 90 degrees approximately and then
they had to figure out
was it rotated clockwise or
counterclockwise
and so they made an assumption they said
okay pick a direction along the sky
we're going to assume that in one
hemisphere uh
all the rotations are clockwise in the
other hemisphere
all the rotations are counterclockwise
and then we're going to ask
what direction if you do that if you
imagine that uh presumption
what direction fits the data the best
okay
and then they fit a straight line so
here's what you have to visualize and
i'll put a link in the paper
to the eventual plot that we made to
make so i'll put a link in the show
notes
to the eventual plot that i made to show
this what you're what you're asking is
what is the change of the um
polarization
versus where how far you are away okay
versus the distance to the galaxy
and what they assumed again is that in
one half of the sky
all the polarizations are in one
direction all the rotations
and the other half it's in the other
direction so if you make a plot on a
piece of graph paper
what it's like doing is saying that by
hypothesis
by construction if you have if you
make your if you divide your graph paper
up into four quadrants
upper right lower right lower left upper
left
by hypothesis the data can only be in
the upper right and the lower left
okay they assumed that all the rotations
for galaxies and one half of the sky
were clockwise and the other half of the
sky were counterclockwise
so they exclude by hypothesis half of
the places where the points could
possibly be
then they fit a straight line through
and they find a non-zero slope
that's a silly thing to do that was not
a good choice
because you are forcing your data to
show you an effect
there's no possible way they could have
failed to see an effect
and what they should have done is they
should have
contrasted that effect they claimed to
find versus a null hypothesis that was
just
everything is perpendicular and there
are no rotations at all
and so uh we realized this was important
and we moved very quickly
and george and i wrote a paper like over
the course of a week
and we said look here's what you should
have done we can do the
analysis of which of these hypotheses is
a better fit hypothesis
one is everything's perpendicular
hypothesis two is
everything is rotated 90 degrees
clockwise in half the sky and
counterclockwise in the other half of
the sky
hypothesis one is a better fit there's
no effect at all
okay so this was fun this was very
exciting
uh we got our paper published in
physical review letters
saying that this was not really an
effect the new york times as far as i
know never retracted their article but
you know that's okay
i'm not i don't put any big blame on the
people who wrote the original paper or
the new york times or anything like that
mistakes are made they're corrected
that's how science goes on
all of this is a way of saying that
there in in the middle of 1997
i suddenly sort of started thinking
about
polarization and lorenzen variants and
turn simon's theories again
okay and cosmic birefringence right so
it was at least in my mind it was not a
hot topic in any sense by anyone's
stretch of the imagination but it was
something that i started thinking about
and george and i around that time wrote
another paper on the magnetic field
problem
as well so then as you as you might know
if you follow the recent history of
astrophysics and cosmology the next year
in 1998 we discovered that the universe
is accelerating okay
uh brian schmidt adam reese and soul
promoter later won the nobel prize for
leading two teams
to show that the universe is
accelerating which we attribute to
dark energy either a cosmological
constant or some form of dynamical
energy
that is pushing the universe apart okay
and i'm not going to go into details
about that right here that'd be another
podcast maybe next year but
this saved my life i mean it literally
saved my career
anyway as an academic because
this was something that now number one
the acceleration of the universe
everyone is interested in this
okay right that's certainly
intrinsically interesting you don't
blame them for being interested in it
it's a huge
game-changing discovery uh and number
two
i was perfectly positioned to write
about it and think about it and do work
on it okay and i thought it was
interesting i was not making any
compromises there
uh brian schmidt was my office mate in
graduate school adam reece lived
in the office below us adam was a recent
guest on mindscape
and uh i'd actually talked to saul
prometer and his group before about
different cosmological
tests that you could do uh with bill
press and ed turner i'd written a review
article
that uh was very very popular about the
cosmological constant
with greg anderson i'd written a paper
about what is now known as dark energy
even though
it wasn't called that at the time so
both on the theory side
and on the experimental side i was in on
the ground floor
as far as the acceleration of the
universe was concerned so once it was
discovered the acceleration of the
universe
it's easy to say well yeah you should
work on that
okay i mean einstein already did the
important work he came up with the
cosmological constant in 1917.
what are you going to do next what else
is there and i think that that was a lot
of the motivation not the only
motivation but part of the motivation
for people thinking about
quintessence quintessence is just the
name that paul steinart and his
collaborators gave to the idea that
there is this scalar field
that is dynamical that is changing with
time but very very slowly
and it pushes the universe apart it's a
dynamical kind of dark energy
so this became a very popular thing to
think about that the dark energy was not
just a cosmological constant an
intrinsic energy density in space but it
was a
scalar field slowly changing with time
that bugged me right away like i got why
people were working on it but
as someone you know the cosmologists
worked on it
the particle physicists rolled their
eyes and the reason why is because they
all
all these models of quintessence were
incredibly finely tuned
okay you may have heard of something
called the hierarchy problem
this is a problem for the higgs boson
the higgs boson
has a mass and we can measure the mass
it's about 125
billion electron volts and by all
rights that mass should be enormously
larger
the quantum mechanical contributions to
that
mass if you sort of separate out the
classical value and the quantum value
the quantum value itself is way larger
than 125 gev so
much like the cosmological constant is
way smaller than we expect it to be the
mass of the higgs boson is also much
smaller than it needs to be
10 to the 2 billion electron volts okay
these quintessence scalar fields are
kind of like the higgs boson they're
scalar fields
they have a mass that mass gets a
contribution from quantum mechanical
effects
but their masses are something like 10
to the minus 40
billion electron volts so if 10 to the
minus 2
is small 10 to the minus 40 is very very
small
sorry 10 to the plus 2 if 10 to the plus
2 is small compared to the natural value
which is up near the planck scale
at 10 to the 18 billion electron volts
then 10 to the minus 40 billion electron
volts is just crazy small
and furthermore there are experimental
tests and so like because i
did care about experimental tests i knew
that if you had light scalar fields if
you had these very very low mass scalar
fields
they're force fields they should couple
to ordinary matter
and people had looked for those
couplings they would violate the
principle of equivalence i'd written
papers about the principle of
equivalence different
kinds of materials would couple with
different strengths
to these new fields and therefore there
would be
composition defendant forces that would
make these new scalar fields very very
visible so even though
everyone got excited about thinking
about quintessence i just uh was a
little bit grumpy about it cause i'm
like oh come on guys you're
being incredibly finely tuned you're
just helping yourself to all these
unnatural
things let's just stick with the
cosmological constant but then i thought
about it
so i said well maybe rather than just
being grumpy you should be productive
you should be
constructive you should actually try to
fix the problems
that these models have so i said is
there any way
to imagine a scalar field that could be
quintessence that could
have an energy that suffused all of
space and pushed the universe apart
in a way to make the universe accelerate
without
being subject to these constraints from
uh fifth forces oh the other constraint
is
the constants of nature should be time
dependent okay this
field should couple again to electrons
into photons and things like that
and that should lead to an apparent
change
in the strength of electromagnetism in
this in what we call the fine structure
constant the number
that uh tells you how strong
electromagnetism is and people had
constrained that
so i actually sat down and i said okay
if you have these natural
values for the coupling of this
quintessence field to ordinary matter
how big should the new forces be how
much should
the fine structure constant and so forth
change and
the predicted changes were bigger by a
lot
uh than the best results that people had
already used to constrain them there's a
whole fun story about where the
constraints come from and so forth the
oklo natural reactor is something you
can
google oklo is a naturally occurring
nuclear reactor that lets you test
the time dependence of fundamental
constants of nature
so anyway the natural coupling constants
or ruled out
even if you help yourself to a very low
mass scalar field
there is a way of eliminating
interactions between
fields when you don't want them when you
have not seen the experimental evidence
for them and that way is called
symmetries symmetries will often
prohibit
certain kinds of couplings between
different fields so
if you say well i demand that my fields
be invariant under the following set of
symmetries
then i'm allowed certain interactions
and not allowed other interactions okay
so there is a particular kind of scalar
field
that can naturally have a very low mass
that's what you want for quintessence
right because otherwise it would have
rolled to the bottom of its potential
instantly instead of taking tens of
billions of years and that kind of
scalar field is called a pseudo
goldstone boson jeffrey goldstone at mit
invented this idea that when you break a
symmetry
there's sort of a mexican hat potential
if you've ever seen these pictures
of a potential for two scalar fields
that have a symmetry between them so you
can rotate them into each other around a
circle
the shape of the potential naturally
looks like a sombrero
or a mexican hat so it's high in the
middle then it goes down to a circle
around the edge and then it goes up
again so when you have that kind of
mexican hat potential
there is a direction in which the field
can move on the brim of the hat
without changing its potential energy at
all and what that means in particle
physics speak is
that direction in which the field can
vibrate has zero mass
so a gold stone boson which jeffrey
invented back in 1960s
goldstone boson has zero mass
automatically
but if you have and this happens this
happens for things like axions and pions
and so forth which i've already
mentioned
if you have almost a symmetry if you
have a symmetry that is pretty good
but is violated a little bit then you
get what is called a pseudo goldstone
boson and it's as if you've taken that
hat and you've tilted it
just by a little bit so you've given
that
scalar field which used to be massless a
little tiny mass by tilting
the brim of the mexican hat and you
might say well
but if i break the symmetry why does it
help you with a low mass at all
and this was actually all worked out by
gerard tuft nobel prize winning
physicist in the 1970s
there's something nice about symmetries
even if they're only approximate
you can naturally have small numbers in
theories of quantum field theory if
there's an approximate symmetry that
protects them
so my point was if you want to have a
quintessence field
you need to have it be very very low
mass and you can't just
say that you need some reason why it's
low mass
so here's a reason why maybe the field
is a pseudo goldstone boson maybe
there's a symmetry
that protects the field from getting a
large mass okay
so if that's true you can ask well what
does that symmetry do to the other
interactions what does that symmetry do
to how the field would couple
to electrons and photons and other
things that i said
could be used to rule out quintessence
fields more generically
and the answer is a limit it eliminates
them it gets rid of them you can't have
couplings uh that would change the fine
structure constant or that would give
rise to fifth forces
if you have the symmetries of a pseudo
goldstone boson
so hooray it works this is this is a
particular kind of quintessence field a
particular kind of dark energy field
um which could be uh natural in the
quantum field theory sense which could
be something which
could be the dark energy without
fine-tuning anything
and by itself that wasn't my idea there
was uh there were previous papers by
josh freeman and other people
um who suggested that pseudo-goldstone
bosons would be natural forms of
dark energy okay my contribution was to
say
not only could it make the mass small it
also makes these couplings
small they they hadn't investigated that
so i said it also saves you
from the constraints of fifth forces and
time-dependent constants except
there is one interaction there is one
thing the pseudoscaler field can do that
is not
squelched by the symmetry that it has
and it is exactly the churn simon's
interaction remember i told you that
this lorentz violating vector field
could be thought of as the gradient of a
pseudoscalar field
so the pseudoscalar field can naturally
couple to electromagnetism
in precisely one way without violating
this symmetry
and that way is what george and roman
and i had looked at back in 1990
okay so in other words
my realization was if you wanted to have
a quintessence field to make the
universe accelerate
but you wanted it to be natural you
didn't want to sort of just
cheat and set some numbers to be very
very small all by themselves
then you could make it a
pseudo-goldstone boson
and it would naturally not just be low
mass but have small couplings
except it would predict there should be
cosmic birefringence the prediction of
this model is that there's one
interaction that is not ruled out and
you can even estimate its size
and that would predict that throughout
the sky there'd be a
uniform rotation in the polarization of
radio galaxies or any other polarized
sources you could imagine okay
and like i said you can you can estimate
the size of the effect
and to my delight the answer was that
it's a very very very very rough
estimate but it was just below
the actual existing limits so it has not
yet been ruled out by actual
data okay so i wrote a paper
about that i wrote a couple other papers
on dark energy and so forth
i was a hot property on the job market
again right not because of me just
because the universe helped me out
and sort of by giving me good things to
work on okay and so i got a faculty job
the university of chicago and and the
rest is history as it were
and so again you know this there turned
out even though i i was sort of hired as
an expert on dark energy theory and i uh
wrote some more papers that were highly
cited about dark energy and modified
gravity and so forth
as far as we can tell now the data just
say the dark energy is a cosmological
constant you know the data are much
better now they were in 1998
i collaborated with the high redshift
supernova team on one of the very first
papers
to uh use this new supernova data to see
whether or not the dark energy could be
changing with time and we found that
you know it could be but probably not
and that continues to be the case and
the room for it to be changing
continues to go down but it's still
there there's still room
for the dark energy density to be
changing a little bit so the idea that
dark energy is
dynamical rather than constant is still
very much on the table
even though it's space uh for being real
has diminished just by a little bit
okay meanwhile other people kept
thinking about this
birefringence thing and in particular um
a bunch of people i think mark
heminkowski
others realized that you know as
wonderful as the radio galaxies were
and and people pointed out by the way
you could do much better than our radio
galaxies like real astronomers got
interested and were able to do
much better than we did numerically um
you could also use the cosmic microwave
background and you know like i said i
had not
delved deeply into the physics of the
cmb so i never thought of this because
roughly speaking you know sure the cmb
has a little bit of polarization
but how would you ever know what it's
polarized
compared to right it's just out there is
this it's the uniform over the sky
so that's because i'm not an expert the
experts like like mark kaminkowski said
look
there is a relationship between the
polarization of the cosmic microwave
background and the temperature
of the cosmic microwave background the
temperature is roughly constant
everywhere but not exactly constant and
that's the whole industry of measuring
anisotropies in the cosmic microwave
background
measuring the tiny little changes in
temperature from place to place
and what mark knew because he was he was
in on the ground floor
in terms of the cmv polarization was
that there is a relationship a predicted
correlation between the direction of the
polarization of the cmb
and the pattern of temperature
anisotropies in the cmb
so he and his collaborators wrote some
papers on potential tests for cosmic
birefringence
using the cosmic microwave background
and i was just in the background
cheering them on i didn't do anything
with it myself and brian keating who i
mentioned
uh as a cosmologist uh do you uh ucsb
said uh no ucsd he's in san diego i was
in santa barbara
so brian has actually developed a
specialty in
looking for cosmic birefringence uh he
is a
cosmic way background experimental
physicist
uh he was one of the first people on the
bicep collaboration and he's now
one of the leaders of the simon's
observatory and one of their big
projects will be
looking for cosmic birefringence okay so
people know about it people have looked
for it uh but it's hard
and i want to emphasize that it's very
very hard because
and even though in some sense the cosmic
microwave background is a wonderful
source of data it's also
the effects are all very very tiny let
me let me um
i know i'm running along already but let
me uh deviate a little bit to tell you
another
little side story that will illustrate
what i mean when i got to caltech
in 2006 um i took on a new student
lottie ackerman um and she and i
collaborated with mark wise who's a
senior person at caltech on asking the
question
what if inflation in the early universe
had happened
in different directions with different
speeds okay so ordinarily inflation
is something where in the early universe
there's kind of super dark energy it
pushes everything apart and smooths
everything out
so we said what if inflation were
anisotropic what if inflation happened
more rapidly in one direction than in
the other two perpendicular directions
so nothing to do with
birefringence or anything like that but
we asked what would happen
and we found that there's a prediction
for the microwave background that there
would be
a sort of a very particular
pattern of variation of the amount of
variation
right so there's variation in the
temperature but imagine that
that overall variation in temperature
from place to place
looked bigger in one direction of the
sky than in the perpendicular direction
of the sky
okay that's that's the prediction that
we made and it turns out that no one had
looked for this
um they'd looked for certain versions of
it but not the version we actually
predicted
and then when you did predict it you
know what we predicted again was that
there's an axis along which the
fluctuations are either bigger or
smaller than in the perpendicular plane
so it's what we call a quadrupole power
asymmetry and no one would look for this
so as soon as we published our paper
lottie and mark and i people did look
for it and they found it right away
now why did we not become famous and why
haven't you heard of this
well because it's a very natural
systematic error
for a cosmic microwave background
satellite you know if you think about
what a cmb satellite does
it looks at the sky tries to look at the
whole sky but it doesn't have one big
antenna that looks at the whole sky at
once it has a pattern that it sort of uh
covers the sky as it sort of spins
around and it's kind of like appealing
the orange kind of pattern right you
like go in some circle but that circle
slowly rotates
so you imagine that there's a lot more
coverage
on one pole and the other pole than
there is on the equator
okay and that turns into a very natural
systematic error that can fool you into
thinking
that you actually see the kind of effect
that lottie and mark and i predicted
there you go all this is just to say
that
finding tiny effects in the cosmic
microwave background is very very hard
to do
people have tried it they haven't found
it okay now here we are
november 2020 i know i'm saying this in
december 2020 but what i mean is in our
story we've caught up to november 2020
and there is uh an announcement of this
new paper in physical review letters by
minami and komatsu
i don't know yuto minami hi there yuto
if you're listening i don't know i've
never met you
ichiro komatsu is a big name he's a very
very accomplished
uh cosmic microwave background physicist
someone who you should take seriously
right so it's not like nobody's out of
nobody's in the middle of nowhere or
just saying crazy things these are
people who know what they're doing
and they have looked very carefully at
data from the planck satellite
okay which look at the polarization of
the microwave background
and i will read you what they say this
is the abstract of their paper we search
for evidence
of parity violating physics in the
planck 2018 polarization data
and report on a new measurement of the
cosmic birefringence angle
dot dot we show that systematic errors
are effectively mitigated
and we find that the polarization angle
is 0.35
degrees plus or minus 0.14
so 0.35 plus or minus 0.14
that excludes the idea that the
angle is 0 at uh 2.4 sigma
which is good but not great honestly
okay
so what they're saying and they're you
know extremely
careful doing everything right they're
not over claiming
they're saying look we found a little
hint of something it should be followed
up we should do better
so i have no idea what to think about
this in other words i'm not going to
tell you this is true
and it's going to be very exciting we've
discovered the dark energy i'm also not
going to tell you it's wrong and it was
a mistake and they just made another
boo-boo okay
these folks know what they're doing
they've analyzed the data i believe
they've analyzed it to the best of
anyone's ability
but a 2.4 sigma result is just not yet
quite enough
to take as as proof of anything
certainly
maybe even as evidence so in particle
physics we have the standard that you
need a three
sigma deviation to get evidence for
something
and a five sigma deviation to get um a
discovery of something so
to get the higgs boson you need a five
sigma result
sigma is the standard deviation it's the
amount that is different from your
measurement
to the hypothesis that the effect isn't
there at all so
you want more and more sigmas more and
more deviation from the expectation
to be able to say i've definitely found
something it's not just a random
error that's just not random numbers
fooling me okay
so 2.4 sigma is 99.2 percent confidence
that sounds pretty good
but the problem in any of these things
is you're always looking for many many
effects
okay so if you find an effect that is
only 1 out of 100 chance
well you've probably looked for 100
effects honestly when you're honest with
yourselves
over the course of your life so you
should find things like that
so 2.4 sigma is that exactly that
tantalizing amount of significance where
it's enough to take seriously you know
it makes you sit up a little more
straight in your chair
but not yet enough to say oh that won't
go away that's a real
thing but one of the reasons why it's
very very interesting is because i
talked about this on
twitter a little bit also um you know
when we did the higgs boson
we crept up on the i say we the royal we
the physics community
uh the very very hardworking
experimental physicist the large hadron
collider
uh you creep up on the significance
right there's an announcement there's
that there's
something there at two sigma and three
sigma and eventually five sigma
et cetera but look everyone thought it
was going to be there
right i mean the higgs boson was part of
the standard model of particle physics
you needed
to have it work okay um so once you were
at three sigma
people were like oh yeah we're gonna get
there in fact literally i got a book
contract out of that right when i wrote
the particle at the end of the universe
i got my contract and
i got my contract right after um they
had gotten three sigma because i didn't
it wasn't my idea to write that book my
editor said the world needs
a book on the higgs boson because
they're going to find it right they're
going to find it and i said yeah they're
going to find it
and he said well we need a book we need
a book by someone who can write who
knows the physics
who can write fast by the time you know
we want the book published by the time
they discover it well that didn't happen
because they discovered it only like six
months later
but at least uh it came out for
christmas that was very nice
um but the point here is that there is a
joke
that has some truth into it that
experimental findings need to be
confirmed by theory
and if you're really hardcore you would
laugh at something like that you go no
no
theory needs to be confirmed by
experiment you should believe your
experimental results but in the real
world in the world where we all live
some experimental results pan out and
some don't and you need to sort of have
a way of judging
whether you put credence in the
different experimental results
when people at cern discovered that
neutrinos were moving faster than the
speed of light
they had good statistical significance
but no one believed them
because it just didn't fit into our
theory at all and eventually they found
they just made a mistake
so there's something like the hubble
tension okay remember i talked with adam
reese on the podcast about this
uh discrepancy between ways of
estimating the value of the hubble
constant today
from data nearby from you know stars and
supernovae and things like that
nearby galaxies versus from data in the
early universe in the microwave
background
and at the pure level of statistical
significance it's quite noticeable
this discrepancy but there's no really
good theoretical explanation for what it
would
be so people are a little reluctant i'm
a little reluctant to take it too
seriously
when adam and his friends in 1998 said
the universe was accelerating
um i and many other people instantly
thought it was right because we had a
very obvious
explanation for it the cosmological
constant and in fact
that solved a whole bunch of other
pre-existing problems in cosmology just
made
everything snap together in a nice way
so
this claim from menominee and komatsu
is kind of in between we have
a uh if it's true that there's cosmic
birefringence if it's true that
the polarization of photons in the
microwave background have all been
rotated a little bit
i don't know maybe clockwise i don't
even know what direction it's in it's a
positive number so maybe clockwise by
0.35 degrees
that is that's easy to explain i
explained it i i put forward a theory
that would predict
almost exactly that you know within the
same order of magnitude
numerically not just the effect exists
but um the magnitude of the effect okay
but okay you know it's still nowhere
near as robust as just saying it's a
cosmological constant
so uh the and the evidence is very very
tentative so
you know the hubble tension which would
be a big deal
um i would say the evidence for it is
pretty solid
except that the theoretical explanation
is completely lacking
this cosmic by refrenchen's claim the
evidence for it is
you know it's it's suggestive but not
nearly as well established only one
group
two people right you would like to see
independent analyses get the same answer
but at least we have an answer to we
have a theoretical explanation to hand
if it turns out to be true
and in fact by the way i think you know
just because i am me and i know what i
did here
uh it's completely possible that there
are other
theoretical explanations that are not
mine right so
it might be that there was some i think
that there are already papers saying
that
well there could be some kind of
pseudoscaler field
in the early universe not now not a
quintessence field
but early universe pseudoscalar fields
that could induce a polarization that
would be rotated
in exactly this way so and that's what
as it should be
if this effect turns out to be true
don't just believe the first possible
explanation
open your mind look for all the possible
explanations so
just to you know put all this in in
context i am
very very very much rooting for this to
be true i would love for this to be
true but i know that i would love for it
to be true that there's some
birefringence out there
and therefore i need to correct for that
right i need to be careful
not to let my enthusiasm get the better
of me and i should
adopt a proper skeptical posture which
is more or less what i've done if you
forced me to bet
at even money um i would bet this is
going to go away
i hope it doesn't and and there's
certainly uh it's more than one percent
chance that it's not going to go away
let's put it that way
between 1 and 50 chance um
so i think this is a good sort of
this whole thing i've gone on a long
time i know i tend to do that but
i think it's a good illustration of a
whole bunch of different ways in which
real theoretical physics gets done okay
real science gets done obviously a lot
of the heavy lifting here is done not by
theorists but by the experimenters
collecting the data
and analyzing it um you know it's not a
lone genius
sitting in their study in their armchair
coming up with brilliant
ideas uh or anything like that it's
highly collaborative
right none of this would have happened
uh you know the first paper
with uh me and george and roman
we all brought something to the
operation like you know roman had the
mathematical chops he had the idea
turned simon's theory in in three
dimensions
george had the you know down-to-earth
realism and the astrophysical chops to
say like we should try this in the real
world and i know how we can test it
and you know but they're both you know i
don't think either one of them
had typed in a lot of data or made any
plots recently in their lives
so you need a graduate student around
who is willing to like the nice thing
about graduate students is
they're not experts at anything
therefore they can do anything because
they know they have to learn whatever it
is you ask them to do whether it's you
know do an integral
or make a plot or learn about topology
or whatever
it's all new to them when you're a
graduate student so you say okay i'll do
it right
when you're an old professor you're like
you're good at some things already
and the idea of like doing something
brand new seems intimidating and
tiresome because i can just do the old
thing that i did
my whole life and became famous doing
right so that was my role
back then i typed in the data and you
know i did catch up by the way
just so you know i caught up so i
understood the theory
behind it and you know could push that
theory forward later on
and you know it didn't go away it was an
interesting idea
many people have followed up in many
different ways i kept thinking about it
we've put the idea to use in other
contexts like magnetic field generation
in the early universe experimentalists
experimentalists are always very very
happy when you make predictions for
something no matter how crazy those
predictions are because they can go test
them
so experimentalists have been thinking
about birefringence now
for a long time and maybe maybe the
state of the art has gotten so good that
we're able to find
this thing that has been there all along
and maybe this is a clue
to what is 70 of the energy density of
the universe right the dark energy is
approximately 70
of the total energy density of the
universe so this could be
the first strong clue that it's not just
the cosmological constant that it's a
field
a pseudoscalar field that is pushing
around photons and their polarizations
an absolute unmistakable if it turns out
to be true
unmistakable example of physics beyond
the standard model of particle physics
because this kind of rotation just
wouldn't exist in conventional physics
so stay tuned 2020 gave us something
good right there you go we got that out
of it
maybe 2021 some other people will
analyze it and show that it's even more
significant and the significance will
creep up from 2.4 to 3.4
and keep going up if that happens i
promise you
at some point i will do another podcast
explaining to you what it all means
okay thanks for listening thanks for
listening all year long
uh it's been yet another wonderful year
of mindscape you know i look over
the people who have appeared on this
podcast and you know no credit to me but
oh my goodness we've had some really
good people on the podcast uh
you know people who are both good
because they're famous and big names and
i'm amazed that they
agreed to come on the podcast but also
people who you've never heard of before
and yet gave tremendously good podcast
interviews because they have interesting
things to say
i always say that i try to mix up the
podcast guests in terms of
not just fields but um level of fame and
level of seniority and things like that
and
so far i think that's working i like it
that uh no one knows ahead of time what
the next
subject is going to be and you know
there's people who go oh yes i've been
waiting for that person and a lot of
people you go i have no idea who this is
and then you listen and go wow i should
know more about them i should read their
books
if you search on twitter i recently did
a twitter thread on all the books from
this year's
podcast guests who have books out this
year it's a it's a long list there's a
lot of very interesting books i
originally hoped to make it
even podcast guests from previous years
if they had new books out this year but
that just became overwhelming too many
books
too many books out there too little time
but that's good
we should read we should get better we
should get smarter hopefully
this podcast here mindscape is doing its
little tiny part
to make us all think a little bit more
make us all a little bit smarter so i
hope you had a good year
over even better things the next year
talk to you in january bye bye
[Music]
you